nouveau à samedi 6 de mobilisation
contre le pass sanitaire le septième
dans toute la france ses opposantes une
nouvelle fois dénoncé la restriction de
leur liberté et notamment avec
l'obligation du pass sanitaires pour les
salariés une obligation qui entre en
vigueur dès lundi notamment dans les
cinémas salles de sport et grands
magasins à paris plusieurs cortèges se
sont une nouvelle fois tenu contrôle
extension de ce pass sanitaires ont fait
le point avec notre reporter nadège
abderrazak
une marche politique et citoyenne
organisée par le collectif paris pour la
liberté le rassemblement a commencé à
place denfert-rochereau en début
d'après-midi alors les manifestants
avaient pour objectif de manifester
devant le ministère de la santé ils ont
reçu un refus catégorique de la part de
la préfecture de police de paris alors
le parcours et s'est finalement achevée
boulevard du montparnasse quoi qu'il en
soit ils sont des milliers à avoir
manifesté pour dire non au pass annie
terre non à l'obligation vaccinale pour
certaines professions et non à la
vaccination des plus jeunes je vous
propose d'écouter certains manifestants
que l'on a pu interroger tout à l'heure
j'arrive pas à comprendre comment on
peut admettre que la vie d'avant qui
était d'aller normalement au restaurant
d'aller normalement dans une salle de
sport vivre vivre normalement
aujourd'hui on soir il veut arriver au
niveau de la chine où on doit avoir un
permis ce que j'ai écrit l'un a permis à
points pour avoir une vie une vie
normale la vie d'avant la vie la vie
tout simplement pas aller dans les cafés
est né à mesure des terrasses alors que
tout le monde parfois on est la distance
on respecte les justesse une barrière
c'est inadmissible et ont tant que
soignant pendant la pandémie tout le
monde était au haut était une sur place
et en assurer un maximum et maintenant
on est montré du doigt ces c'est comme
si on était pestiféré impasse sanitaire
une obligation vaccinale pour certaines
professions de dispositifs de lutte
contre la propagation du colis 19
qualifiée de liberticide par de nombreux
manifestants ici présents dont
l'organisatrice de ce rassemblement
sophie tissier qu'on soutient vue
fondamentalement les personnes y en qui
subissent cette obligation de
vaccination et l'échéance arrive donc
absolument qu en face au monde et un
grand mouvement citoyen plus pacifique
c'est pour ça qu'on est en blanc parce
que c'est la couleur de la paix et la
démocratie etc les blouses blanches et
on dénonce le l'instauration de ce pass
sanitaire qu'on considère comme étant
vraiment le summum du contrôle des
citoyens on est en pleine dictature
sanitaire masqué alors parce que l'on
instrumentalise la peur de ce virus dont
on se sert de la peur sur les gens pour
leur faire passer toutes ces lois
scélérates dictatorial et cette
mobilisation aujourd'hui c'était une
sorte de répétition générale pour la
grande mobilisation du 11 septembre
prochain qui doit notamment réunir des
personnels de santé des pompiers ou
encore des gendarmes et tous ceux
finalement qui s'oppose le pass
sanitaire et à la vaccination
obligatoire et des manifestants qui ont
certainement pour objectif de faire
reculer le gouvernement sur ces deux
dispositifs